dea
今から日本語の講座を行います
4 urara
[音楽]
tan tan
もしもしじゃあもうそもそれをれていたれ
同源だよ峠統計今どんな動画作ってノーかなぁと思って電話してみた
あのたぶん間違い電話だと思います同源という形にあった記憶がちょっとなくて6月に
youtube の集まりでたくさん話したじゃう
申します
を
もしかしてそうそうそうあるもの友達やその
今から日本語の講座を行いますって言う人いつもニット帽かぶってる人になぜ者である
さあ as our heart パティ地域 pr 旧モデル化
あっあっ
濃いなあ
8 pdr の三毛猫の名前が本だったら面白いなに寝たら2匹の名前はした時はしで
もなっちゃうし
したらしーの本なっちゃうしスコティッシュフォールドの名前は知らもんだから
だからスコティッシュフォールドの名前は[ __ ]じゃなくて
品もそうするとラテのままえお盆に変えたら二人の名前を合わせてシナボンじゃなくて
シナモン本になるから
てキャッチ
死ぬ者本あとさーさっきお前の動画見たんだけどマジつまんねー
神の本何の良いのならないと3名のこの前の動画面白かったって伝えてくれる彼女が
それを twitter でフォローした貨客喜んでくれると思うんだよねいいけど
ちょっと待っはがかかってきたかなぁ今だけ
desiree sapere us army どぇ
remedios はフィナーレプレイシスレー
released to do あ
写真は指ケ版今から日本語の講座ウィザーズ pere
ん ni
ウザ棒
道具